-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with my family
and it does seem like Dad's
maybe wrapping up. Mom, you want
to unmute him real quick?
-So --
-Alright.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, anyway, it's a great story.
It's one of Hilary's favorites,
[ Laughter ]
so, I'm glad I was able
to tell it tonight.
-It was really good.
It was really good, Dad.
-Yeah.
-Everybody here liked it a lot.
-You know what?
I can't hear the audience,
really, being remote like this,
but I really just got the sense
that they really enjoyed it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
They really, really loved it.
-Just from the expressions
on your faces,
I think it really tracked
with them.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
I'm glad you guys liked it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, yeah, give him his round
of applause. Well-deserved.
So, you guys showed up,
came over.
First thing you did was stop
at the apartment, my apartment.
I was here at work.
-Mm-hmm.
-You got in early, couldn't
check into your hotel yet.
Did you enjoy? Were you happy
to come to my apartment?
Was it, uh, hospital --
hospitable?
-It's colder
inside than outside.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like in New York, in November.
And your television
doesn't work.
-Nope.
[ Laughter ]
-There's mustard, I think,
in the fridge,
but not much else.
-No, we always like
to have one jar of mustard.
It's a way of letting
our guests know they're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
So, yeah.
-Now, what are your requests
when you come stay at a home?
We've left a spoiler.
There's been an Easter egg
already in this interview.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright.
Beverages.
See, I drink sparkling water.
I drink grapefruit juice.
I drink gin, I drink tonic,
and sometimes I'll drink beer
and sometimes I'll drink wine.
-Now, what do we have?
-Water.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Not even sparkling water.
-No, it comes right
from the tap.
-I know.
-[ Smooch ]
[ Laughter ]
Look, you're getting
your free drinks elsewhere.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you did make
a special trip
and went out and bought gin
and soda.
-I made a mistake, yeah.
-Everyone loves
a nice gin and soda.
-I knew my mom was coming and I
went out to get gin and tonic
and I accidentally
got gin and soda,
a drink no one orders.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Josh, one of the other
things that has been --
I guess you've had to be
a little creative,
in recent years,
about Thanksgiving
and, in general, you're a vegan,
now, for how many years?
-Coming on three.
And recently visited
Mom and Dad.
And you, very sweetly,
went out of your way
to make sure
that he was taken care of.
-Yeah.
Kale and chickpea
and it was a soup with --
-So, what kind of soup was it?
Like a kale-chickpea soup?
-Kale-chickpea soup, yep.
-Was it good, Josh?
-Yeah, it was a New York Times
recipe, I want to say.
-Yeah.
-Like she cut it out special
-Delicious.
-and prepped for my arrival.
-You, as a son,
you must feel loved
when that happened.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Dad, was there any errors
in the soup?
[ Alert chimes ]
-Just one.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, there were a lot
of ingredients and a lot to do.
The problem was that, instead
of using vegetable broth --
she came so close and --
[ Laughter ]
very close.
But she used chicken broth.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So, it wasn't vegan.
And, now, did you --
-That's probably
why it was so good, but...
[ Laughter ]
...it wasn't vegan and Josh came
down the next morning and said,
"Did you use chicken broth
in that soup?
Because my stomach's
a little upset."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
But she came really close.
-She really came close.
You know, if there's only one
ingredient in there,
that's pretty close.
-Yeah.
I tried.
-You know, the thing is --
Yeah.
-You know, one would say
you could maybe be
as forgiving about gin and soda.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
One could say that.
-One could say that.
-The thing that concerns me is
that I know she's been trying
to poison me,
but I never thought she'd try
to poison Josh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
That's about --
Once you get a taste
of the poisoning,
you just start doing it
to everyone.
But, Josh, anyway, it is --
I do hope -- I know
you're going back to L.A.
I do hope you have
a great vegan Thanksgiving.
-Yeah, I will.
And I don't like --
I know it gets tedious
for like vegans
to talk about being vegans...
-Yeah.
-...but I did write a song
about it
[ Laughter ]
and I don't know
if I can sing that.
-Oh, we don't have time, but --
-No, perfect, perfect.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Band play bright tune ]
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Seth, do you think
animals like you?
-I don't think about it at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, they probably don't,
because you eat them,
but I wrote a verse
about how they like me.
Can I sing that one?
-We are out of time.
-2, 3, 4.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh!
Big and plump.
I like that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
Look at this.
[ Crunch ]
Mmm!
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Ooh! Ooh!
Man.
This is raw.
[ Laughter ]
Unsalted.
[ Crunch ]
Mmm!
Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that the same nut?
-Mmm.
Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
Oh!
It was a big nut.
[ Laughter ]
Eli.
♪ And, oh, if tofu
is too gross for you ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Josh Meyers with the new
Thanksgiving vegan anthem.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."